les chéris on va faire une transition
toute trouvée puisque on va faire le top
rigolade de la télé les cinq vidéos
drôles de la tissot sont passés à la
télé et pas la télé d'ailleurs aussi en
numéro 5 on voit plein de gens se mettre
au yoga depuis quelques jours il ya une
nana qui sait filmer sauf que son chien
lui a fait une petite visite en même
temps regarder ces numéros sous la peau
le poète ça va ils ces pays s'est fait
plaisir c'est bon vous fait qu'un petit
show de yoga sophie cost non je déteste
ça tout ce que méditation yoga etc c'est
un mois je suis plutôt sport de combat à
krav maga boxe j'adore faudra qu'on
fasse un combat un jour avec grand
plaisir sauf les gens me voulait vague
de vous offrir un combat avec sophie
d'ailleurs j'aimerais bien faire basso
france va de sophie jean-mi jeu pour
amer on en voulait ce soir vous voyez
comment mais on se voit on voit avec
évidemment toutes les masques non parce
que j'ai un dégât des eaux à la maison
jean mitry et mon voisin là il est plus
bien maintenant wemade et prier et du
ton dès la clôture
le mec quoi il m'a dit qu'il s'y
connaissait beaucoup en plomberie
derrière du tout alors là les citoyens
de rien du tout sauf il est fier vous
quand même si vous avez un gros souci
matin comme si on regardait confinement
jeu le prendre au téléphone je cesserai
de le gérer en numéro 4 des vidéos d'art
cas on n'arrête pas de dire pendant le
confinement on découvre plein de talent
il ya un mec son talent à lui c'est de
refaire à la perfection une scène de
flashdance pourra peut être falloir
regarder
[Musique]
m
g
[Musique]
et ça fait plaisir d'avoir retrouvé mon
cousin de proches voilà c'est la famille
ça c'est la classe et là c'est la
famille proche
les cherry en numéro 3 il ya une maman
qui a interrogé son fils sur le
confinement pour voir s'il était un peu
au courant de ce qui se passait en ce
moment et regardez vous allez voir la
vérité sort toujours de la bouche des
enfants
regarde et dit moi mon bébé pourquoi on
ne peut pas aller dehors comme ac
ronaldinho comme huawei ce qu'il a à
dire oui parce que y'a quoi et il
s'appelle comment le virus est légal me
l'imaginer franchement il va avoir des
problèmes là là ça va être chaud ça va
être chaud cause elle est géniale le
petit prince pour aller au numéro 2
c'est le tard bas de la semaine
il ya sa femme qui lui demandent de la
prendre en photo sauf que le mec a
trouvé mieux à regarder que de prendre
sa femme en photos regarder
[Musique]
non
marine
c'est dégueulasse moi je mourrai c'est
original ac ou c'est vous savez on est
on est confient les gens me vous
emmerdez pas vous allez déjà joué des
plombiers demain vous calmez vous les
cherry en numéro 1 des vidéos d'arca
imagine vous êtes tromperie vous êtes
bien vous êtes dans votre bain en plein
confinement et la ja votre chat qui
décide de vous faire un kiff en vous
apportant un cadeau bien bien ripoux
genre un truc dégueulasse
regardez
[Musique]
[ __ ] j'en peu que ces deux mondes
tranquille et là il ya des chats qui
ramène un oiseau crever sont peu plus
aux [ __ ] hôpitaux belges adorent
proches signalent également
elle est géniale elle et elle ont là
devant vous voulez le voir sans regarder
regardez
[Musique]
[ __ ] j'en peux plus je suis dans mon
bain tranquille et là il ya des chats
qui ramène un oiseau outre les gens peu
plus haut [ __ ] [ __ ] ça va c'est
génial au loin il ya beaucoup beaucoup
de pays qui chérit